hillary clinton is going after donald
trump in a flurry of interviews recently
you think our democracy is under
continuing assault by um the former
president i think he poses a real clear
and present danger to the united states
and having lived through
that presidency
when it came time to write a political
thriller with my friend and collaborator
louise penny of course i would draw from
the reality that we all have experienced
so her present day media blitz is
fueling speculation that she's testing
the waters for a potential 2024
presidential run
team trump clapped back at their 2016
rival saying
perennial loser hillary clinton appears
to have recognized that her only
marketable attribute is that she lost to
donald j trump
well they didn't mince words jimmy fayla
host of fox across america on fox news
radio great show tune in
so uh jimmy i mean is she dialing it
back a little bit like back to those
those days of pre-2016 so she can let
people see what they missed well she's
absolutely
going to run again harris i said this on
your show two weeks ago we don't have
that confirmed harris stop it is that
your spidey sense hillary clinton is the
political equivalent of a stray cat we
fed once and now it will never go away
like of course like she's revealing that
this book had something to do with trump
yo hillary we know that because this is
so emotional for her it's denying her
the self-awareness that would otherwise
tell her she sounds like a crazy person
you know somebody who goes through an
axe you know who goes through a breakup
and they can't stop bringing up their
action like hey hilary how's your lunch
oh it's warm unlike donald who wasn't
warm at all it's like we get it you're
obsessed with the guy she needs to move
on because the rest of us have but i
don't think she sees you know any world
where she's comfortable doing that well
look uh focusing on him has not worked
for democrats i mean
it's it well it may have worked for
biden
now that we see that it probably wasn't
coveted because that's gotten worse but
anyway uh vice president kamala harris's
staff attempting to pull the plug on an
interview and how they did it we'll
leave you crying uh laughing she was
pressed on
really who is the president
i want to know who's the real president
of this country is it by is it joe biden
or joe manchin
i'm so sorry charlie
she can hear me
can can hear me now they're acting like
they can't hear me
i can hear you oh so who's there
so who's the real president of this
country is it joe manchin or joe biden
madam vice president come on charlemagne
i really don't it's joe buddy i can't
tell sometimes no no no no no
it's joe biden and don't start talking
like a republican about asking whether
or not he's president do you think joe
manchin is a problem
it's joba and it's joe biden and i'm
vice president my name is kamala harris
jimmy fella
sassy oh no you didn't listen where was
simone to cut her off when she was lying
about visiting our southern border when
she was sitting down with lester holt
what i'm bothered by in that interview
is that the democrats specifically this
administration they have such an
entitled attitude when it comes to black
support don't forget this is the same
charlemagne show where joe biden said if
you have a problem figuring out if
you're familiar trump then you ain't
black and then what did kamala do she
did the old don't start talking like a
republican as if she's just allowed to
shut him down because he's not entitled
to dare question what's going on in an
administration that oh by the way is
crushing working-class americans you
know so the whole point here okay is
that kamala has a huge authenticity
issue and it's bled beyond republicans
it's why this administration isn't
polling well with independence and it's
why a guy like charlemagne who supports
their policies which i think is wrong is
still not going to take them at their
word on anything wow well look uh it
seemed to be at that point when you just
that wasn't even the whole interview as
you listened to more and more of it i
mean they were trying to stop this and
she wanted to speak up but when she did
i don't know that it made a difference
no that well that's the thing and she
just hit him with the old oh you're a
republican okay there's no case to be
made for this bill it raises inflation
it raises taxes at a time when americans
are struggling this is the financial
equivalent of throwing a drowning man a
sofa stop it with this bill kamala uh
the white house doing a big cleanup on
aisle six after the president
accidentally gave his vice president a
job promotion
during a commencement speech it's
happened before watch harris
is a proud howard alum
she might have something to say about
delaware state
he called her president harris the white
house corrected that mistake by adding
vice to the official transcript so they
actually changed the document but not
what came out of his mouth because it
had already happened this not the first
time as i mentioned biden called his vp
president
back in march
listen there's no one i feel worse for
than the guy who edits these speeches or
the sign language interpreter who has to
take what joe says and turn it into real
words because nine times out of ten they
aren't real words but here's the thing
harris i actually have a theory i don't
think this is a sign of cognitive
decline i think we have seen those signs
in other areas and fair or unfair you
know if you're the oldest president ever
to hold the office these flubs are going
to be associated with such things biden
is holding office in his late hundreds
if you say the wrong name people are
gonna be like oh well but here's my
theory really quick harris i think he
says president harris on purpose because
it makes him seem more appealing you
know you watch biden you're like oh this
guy's a mess but then you hear the term
president harris and you're like joe get
back here we need you
i think it's genius wow that's that's
really interesting by the way last week
when she said oh no no we haven't talked
about running in 2024. even though the
white house is floating out that they're
definitely running in 2024.
uh yeah okay they're they're not running
the five harris they're not running a 5k
in 2024. stop it
jimmy fella you are going to be so funny
you're going to kill it on new year's
eve oh there's i'm grateful that you
that you stopped by the focus to talk
about the serious stuff you're the best
and make us laugh at the same time
thanks queen
it's not the weekend it's only monday